لذلك هذا جزء من مسابقة فزاعة
حرب النجوم هي مجرد شيء
نحبه نحن مهووسون بالخيال العلمي
بمجرد أن علقت في رأسي لم
أستطع الحصول على أي أفكار أخرى
إذا كنت قد أخذت فصلًا  ربما
قبل خمس سنوات لنحت العجين الميت ،
كان الأمر أشبه بعمل الأشكال والأشياء الأساسية ،
لكنني لم أر في الواقع
منحوتة بالحجم الطبيعي بالكامل ، لذا
فكرت أنا وأمي لماذا لا
نعطيها لقطة
أجنبية
[موسيقى  ]
لا يستطيع الناس إبعاد أيديهم عن
التمثال ، فهم يداعبونهم
ويلمسونهم ويضربونهم ، وكان
علينا إصلاحهم ثلاث مرات
منذ أن أخرجناهم لأن لديه
ثقوبًا يشمها الناس
يصعدون ويذهبون لشمّهم وهم
يحاولون اكتشاف ما هو مصنوع من
[موسيقى] ،
فمن
المحتمل أن يصبح متعفنًا قليلاً أو
شيء من
المحتمل أن أقوم بتسميده
في نهاية الموسم بعد
الهالوين وحفظ الخشب الرقائقي  للعام المقبل